was soll das von Daten des Jahres
Militär des Jahres 2022 und das sind die
Preisträger in der Kategorie recruit des
Jahres Georg Felbers sorgt im
militärischen cyberzentrum für noch mehr
Sicherheit
in der Kategorie zivilbediensteter des
Jahres
wurden der erste Österreicher der bei
scientifikate Report den Vorsitz inne
hat die SAP ist die Organisation für ein
Verbot chemischer Waffen
in der Kategorie Einheit des Jahres die
zweite jägerkompanie des jägerpartagnose
18 ausgezeichnet für die Vielzahl der
unterschiedlichsten Einsätze und die
dadurch bewiesene Flexibilität
in der Kategorie Soldat Soldaten des
Jahres
beweist das auch Spätberufene beim
Bundesheer noch alles erreichen können
was Sie sich wünschen
in der Kategorie special Awards Laudator
Christian freut sich fünf Offiziere des
Bundesheeres für ihre hoch anerkannte
Medienarbeit die sich selbst Februar
dieses Jahres leisten auszuzeichnen
[Musik]
das sind die Preisträger des Militär des
Jahres 2022
[Musik]